wir schaffen es nicht mehr ja das sagen
auch immer mehr Landräte die nicht mehr
wissen wie sie die Steine Zahlen
Flüchtlingen unterbringen sollen kurz
vorm großen flüchtlingsgipfel heute in
Berlin platzte auch einem grünen Landrat
der Kragen Jens Marco Scherf er sagte
wörtlich bei Markus Lanz im Talk wenn
Integration gelingen soll müssen wir den
Mut haben Missstände ganz offen
anzusprechen er forderte die gesamte
Flüchtlingspolitik zu überdenken führte
eine ganze Liste an Problemen an es
kennen zu viele Flüchtlinge und
Migranten die Kommunen hätten kaum noch
Wohnraum und zu wenig Personal sein
Landkreis Miltenberg in Bayern bräuchte
jede Woche eine neue Flüchtling zu
Unterkunft und dass er einfach nicht
zustimmen er selten hatten grünen
Politiker so deutlich Klartext
gesprochen beim Thema Migration kommt
bekamer Schafe Kritik auch aus den
eigenen Reihen Parteikollegen legten ihm
mal die Grünen zu verlassen hier schlägt
also ein grüner landraum Landrat Alarm
was sagt das Peter über die aktuelle
flüchtlingskrise und wie wir damit
umgehen eigentlich
also wer an der Basis arbeitet der
begegnet ja da Wirklichkeit und wer in
einer Blase arbeitet der grenzt die
Wirklichkeit aus und wir sehen es ja
nicht nur bei diesem Landrat sondern
vorher schon bei Boris Palmer und bei
anderen Grünen auch die die an der Basis
arbeiten die die täglichen Probleme
haben die damit umgehen müssen die
sprechen Klartext und die können auch
nicht mehr und da spielt das Parteibuch
schlichtunter greifen überhaupt gar
keine Rolle wer in den Kommunen und in
den Landratsämtern arbeitet der hat
jeden Tag dieses Problem wir können es
nicht weg diskutieren es lässt sich
nicht mit Ideologie bearbeiten und
herzlich willkommen in der Wirklichkeit
dann auch der großen grünen Blase das
sind nicht nur die Grünen das ist bei
der SPD auch so wir haben es auch in der
Union in Teilen von Union auch in Teilen
von der FDP haben wir das selber Problem
dass ab einer bestimmten Ebene
Wirklichkeit einfach ausgeblendet oder
verneint wird und aber mit Navigation
das hat man schon eine zumindest nicht
noch in meiner komischen Ostschule
wollte noch max und Leni noch gelernt
noch gelernt habe also als die
Elektriker habe ich die ganze
funktioniert nicht also die Wirklichkeit
muss wahrgenommen werden und die kann
man nicht ausblenden und jetzt
gleichzeitig die bekommt er von
Parteikollegen nahegelegt er möge sich
mal jetzt freiwillig aus der Partei
verabschieden was sagt das auch aus es
ist so weit gekommen dass man quasi
mundtot gemacht wird wenn man mal
Klartext spricht und das mal ganz
überspitzt zu sagen ja das wird ja
sicherlich heute auch Thema sein zum
Thema Corona wir haben es in den letzten
Jahren gesehen wer mal Klartext redet
und der Tiger hat recht ich bin selbst
Kommunalpolitiker da ist man ganz
schnell in der Schublade oder als
schwuppler ja
verbrannt kann man nicht anders sagen
und ich finde es ich finde schon
abenteuerlich dass das die Grünen ähm
aber sie haben vollkommen recht das ist
bei jeder Partei eigentlich momentan so
wer Klartext spricht unter der Basis
arbeitet der weiß was los ist und das
kommt hier in der Blase in Berlin aber
auch in landshagen anscheinend nicht an
und fruchtig irgendwie verlernt vor
Neigel ganz sachlich über die sachlichen
Themen miteinander zu diskutieren wird
es gleich persönlich wird es gleich ein
Angriff so wieder auch da in diesem Fall
also ob ich ob wir das allgemein
verlernt haben das mag ich nicht
beurteilen ich denke wir können das
jederzeit wieder aufleben lassen aber
die Situation die durch die
corona-politik stattgefunden hat da
wurde auch seitens der polit der
führenden Politik sehr häufig mit
dialektischer eristik argumentiert das
bedeutet es ging immer sofort unter die
Gürtellinie also wenn irgendjemand eine
angemessene und konstruktive Kritik
geäußert das habe ich ganz oft erlebt
mit sachlichen Argumenten und man konnte
dem Argument nichts entgegensetzen dann
wurde sofort persönlich argumentiert man
wurde die Familie die Menschen wurden
diskriminiert das haben wir ja ganz oft
erlebt dass jetzt im Nachhinein dann
auch es heißt ja dieser Kritiker hat
eigentlich Dinge vorausgesehen oder auch
vor etwas gewarnt was heute realistisch
gesehen fakt ist und der Flüchtlings
Diskussion haben Sie den Eindruck da
verläuft das ähnlich oder haben sie da
die Hoffnung dass wir das sachlich ich
habe das also ich habe so und so immer
die Hoffnung dass wir da zurückkehren
auf die sachliche Ebene wie wir es ja
und Jahrzehnte lang gekannt haben denn
das war eigentlich unsere ganz normale
offene Disco ist Kultur und ich denke es
liegt an uns an der Gesellschaft denn
auch die Politiker die das eingeführt
hatten den es dann natürlich auch
leichter gewisse rigide Maßnahmen
durchzusetzen den müssen wir es
abgewöhnen ich denke wir Ihnen innerhalb
der Gesellschaft können es eigentlich
leichter stemmen weil wir natürlich auch
friedlich miteinander diskutieren wollen
merken Sie auch bei in ihrer Heimat des
Kommunen zum Teil überlastet sind das
ist da Probleme
Ludwigshafen und da ist es zum Beispiel
ganz offenkundig und auch in Mannheim
dass das also die die Kommunen
überlastet sind dass man auch praktisch
kaum noch weiß wo man sie alle
unterbringen soll und dann sehen Sie
dazu im Alltag ist jedes im Alltag ich
sehe natürlich auch Gruppierungen von
von Menschen von denen man offenkundig
sieht die kommen jetzt frisch hierher
die sind nicht gewohnt hier hier
ansässig zu sein sprechen vielleicht
auch ein gar kein Deutsch im Moment aber
das ist eigentlich der weniger das
wenigere Problem das geringere Problem
das größere Problem ist die Masse es
geht eher um die Masse und ich habe auch
gelesen das ist tatsächlich sogar um
Diskussionen gegen dass man bestimmten
Hausbesitzern die häus enteignen oder
wegnehmen möchte um die zu befüllen mit
Flüchtlingen ich finde es geht einfach
zu weit sie kam ja selbst als Kind in
ein fremdes Land wie haben sie das
erlebt wird auch einfach zu wenig
geholfen also um das auch mal von der
anderen Seite zu beobachten da sind ja
auch Menschen die alleine gelassen
werden die auch nicht wissen wohin mit
sich in großer Not sie meinen jetzt die
Flüchtlinge die kommen also ich kann die
Situation die wir damals hatten nicht
mich jetzt vergleichen wir sind aus wir
sind nach dem kriegsverschleppten Gesetz
hierher gekommen aus der UdSSR nach
Deutschland in den 70ern wir hatten wir
haben weniger Hilfe gekriegt als man
sich das vorstellen kann jeder von uns
musste selbstständig Deutschland sich
selbstständig integrieren und von Geld
oder irgendwelchen anderen Dingen war da
gar nicht die reden mussten uns das
selbst erarbeiten und ich persönlich
habe mich darüber nicht beklagt ich bin
sehr dankbar dafür dass wir in unsere
Heimat in dem Falle zurück dürfen und
ich ich glaube das ist halt für jedes
Land einfach Grenzen der Masse gibt es
es geht nicht darum humanitäre Hilfe zu
leisten das ist notwendig aber aber es
geht einfach um die Masse und es geht
vor allen Dingen um vernünftige
Maßnahmen und vernünftige Politik und
Angemessenheit sie sind Richter geht es
ihnen so dass sie eine sachliche
Diskussion vermissen wir gehen gleich
ganz tief rein in ihrer auch sehr
persönliche Geschichte aber einmal noch
haben an diesem Thema dran zu bleiben
wenn wir das verlernt dass wir da über
die Sachthemen diskutieren den Finger
auch mal in die Wunder halten auch mal
das aufzeigen was nicht funktioniert
ohne dass gleich beispielsweise damit
gedroht wird man soll die Partei
verlassen besser naja also wenn ich
meine Arbeit mache wird natürlich
sachlich diskutiert weil dann ja ein
Fall 60 zu bewirken ist wenn man das
nicht sagt ich machen würde würde die
Arbeit schlecht gemacht werden von daher
ist das natürlich schon sehr sachlich
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie